if you place a typical bar magnet close
to another
they will attract or repel each other
depending on which way their poles are
facing
the worldly wisdom is that north
attracts south and same poles
repel but this is merely a description
what is physically happening at these
ends
michael faraday proposed that the lines
of force that constitute a magnetic
field are real
and james maxwell said that there is
matter in motion in that space
indeed a magnetic field is definitely
comprised of moving matter
of an exotic nature
this becomes evident when you realize
that a magnetic field has the ability to
pull one iron filing at a time
when underwater these lines of force
sweep around the outside of a magnet
and through its center they flow
into the south pole and come out of the
north
the fields of two magnets merge during
attraction
the task done is to identify the
physical medium the secret agents that
constitute the magnetic field
the rope hypothesis proposes that any
two atoms are bound by an entity
that resembles a rope a twine pair of
threads
all atoms in existence are physically
connected
under this model electricity consists of
a string of atoms
that have merged to form a serpentine
this serpentine spins in place
keep in mind that under the right hand
rule
the magnetic field runs perpendicular to
the electric field
the serpentine spins very fast
and induces threads to separate from the
rope they formed
the rope model of magnetism proposes
that faraday's lines of force
are physical threats that acquire our
everyday macro world property of touch
by aggregation countless threats
form the magnetic field of a magnet
let's now visualize how these swinging
threads produce attraction
and repulsion
we begin with an analogy to get a grip
on the basic mechanisms
imagine two brothers axel and rod
skipping next to each other
their ropes are swinging clockwise
the ropes interact axon rod are drawn
toward each other as a result of this
interaction
rod now turns around and faces axel
their jump ropes now clash and push each
other away
let's now extrapolate these mechanisms
to magnets
it is misleading to divide a magnet the
traditional way
into north and south poles
in order to understand the mechanisms of
attraction and repulsion
it is more profitable to divide a magnet
into top and bottom halves
consistent with our experience with
lines of force the threads on the top
half swing around
enter the traditional south end slide
along the interface between top and
bottom
halves and come out the traditional
north pole
the threads on the bottom half sweep
around in the opposite direction
in a mirror image of those on the top
let's now look at what happens at the
four corners of two magnets that face
each other
north to south
on the top half of the first magnet the
threads are swinging counterclockwise
on the top half of the second magnet the
threads are also swinging
counterclockwise
the threads on the first magnet come up
and latch on to the threads of the other
magnet when they come down
the threads on the bottom half of the
two magnets swing in the opposite
direction
the threads of the first magnet swing
clockwise and those of the second magnet
also suing
clockwise the threads of the first come
down
and latch onto the threads of the second
magnet which are coming up
the threads go through each other
despite a faint subatomic friction
the more threads that intervene the
stronger the attraction between the two
magnets
the number of threads that participate
is a function of distance
if we turn the second magnet around 180
degrees
the threads on top and bottom halves now
swing in opposite directions
and clash against each other the farther
the magnets are apart
the fewer threads that intervene and the
weaker is the strength of the repulsion
the rope model of magnetism explains the
invisible mechanism that underlies
attraction
and repulsion
[Music]
you